[Music]
let's get into the jake and liberty
thing straight away
yeah because you know why you don't want
to talk about the nothing burger that
priya and brett were
actually no okay we can talk about them
first just because of how
infuriating it was in last night's
episode where they're playing that
stupid-ass
game
actually the game wasn't that stupid the
game was pretty entertaining it was like
finding out who the uk thinks is the
least compatible couple or the smartest
couple or the most
uh athletic or whatever the [ __ ] it was
yeah um
and they
the smartest category came up who do you
guys think the smartest couple or who do
you guys think the uk voted as the
smartest couple in the house is and both
of them were like
and
and they were like and they just kept
hamming it up they kept being like if
i'm if i'm not up there i'm gonna be mad
and then she's like cussed to her in the
talking head room and she was like if i
didn't win that i would be it's like we
[ __ ] get it you're a [ __ ] medical
student we get it nobody gives a [ __ ]
this isn't
uk's top medical student reality show it
does literally doesn't matter at all
also you didn't finish yet
what do you mean she didn't finish
school yet
she's not she's not done
yeah so it's like
who knows rhett was the same he was like
yeah where's yoga's phd it's like you
don't have one yet doofus is this what
is this
hottest phd students of the uk
[Laughter]
no one cares dude also how when she
walked that small right
[Laughter]
when they volunteered themselves up
there and no one cared yeah that is like
indicative of real life no one cares how
people don't give a [ __ ] yeah we're
smart yeah you're all so [ __ ] boring
yeah the gall she had to call him boring
yeah but when hers like
actually you know what she's not that
bad
she actually is not that marathon
running got you
i gotta admit i went on our instagram
briefly yeah and uh just to see what's
up you know yeah of course i like to see
what their lives were like before the
show what they look like what they
what they cause you can tell what's like
important to them or whatever and uh
yeah she had one post go down scroll
scroll down so this is in april uh
150 kilometers she ran 150 kilometers
she did 100 000 steps a day and she did
58 at 45 classes in 15 days
she definitely at 45 are 45 minute
workout classes that are like super hard
she did 50 of them in 15 days
how
okay let's do the math there
um that's three a day it's over three a
day
yeah
what what yeah you definitely don't have
a boyfriend or a job
how are you at medical school yeah how
are you doing all that spent an hour and
45 minutes
or what what is that two two hours and
fifteen minutes is that what that is you
know what no you know what i you know
what that is
it's cap
yeah
yeah it's being a cat
sorry i just
i smell something in the air reading
that 50 classes in
15 days yeah
i don't what is that
i don't know i just
i just i smell
something what is that if you're
listening on audio i'm
smelling a new tmg bucket hat
except you know what what those actually
don't smell because they're so
breathable they are actually very
breathable it's a very nice material you
know back to hating on a woman's workout
routine
okay
i
i'm impressed by that oh yeah that's the
type of [ __ ] i like to see i just don't
know how that's possible yeah
you would like her to show you how it's
possible no i'm joking i'm joking i'm
joking
[ __ ] dude there's no way a girl
could work out no but what i was gonna
say is that
she
i don't think she's that boring because
she was actually really funny in that
[ __ ] ceremony they had after they all
banged yeah
she was pretty funny in that yeah wait
after they all banged don't you remember
that yeah we didn't talk about that oh
yeah everybody that was [ __ ] oh yeah
because everybody
the biggest [ __ ] part of the yeah the
first episode after last
our episode mm-hmm
yeah everyone got horny why did they get
horny again
because they're all like
they're all like just super into their
dudes
so they're all like we're gonna let them
smash i thought they played i thought it
was after the lap dance
thing they all got horned up was it
i'm pretty sure that's what it was you
guys remember
because uh cause um
i thought it was before that
no i thought it was the lap dance and
then they all got horned up and then
everyone was like yeah i let him
i did i did yeah i did they're all you
know celebrating that's the first time
i've seen that happen on the show though
yeah just straight
they all just like collectively decided
we're all gonna bang in the same room
that's never happened before well not
priya
not priya but brett had to just lay
there and listen to [ __ ]
i mean not only that it's like
yeah
just all over the room just different
sort of
or just rustling comforters just
i like to think they just go full blown
legs in the air
quite quiet quite quiet oh yes
commensurate
i fancy this i can't see this i fancy
this yeah right yeah um oh inquisitive
you are so fit you are so fit absolutely
inquisitive um
quite what do you think hugo sounds like
he's getting knobbed off
not that that's such a sus ass question
just gotta take the l on that
so that's the problem when you try to
write sketch in real time you're just
liable to say some gay [ __ ]
i mean just i i can't i've never heard
that dude whisper
you know so you know like you might get
topped off you might let out a little
like
like a little like soft but hugo is like
oh yeah
oh you're lying yeah yeah
near the top yeah i like that
i do like when you suck near the top
i'm still stuck on what do you think he
sounds like ginseng getting hit
what do you think that guy sounds like
good head i mean he's just you know
i thought it was an annoying ass voice
and i just pictured him being like
all right job done yeah job john donny
how many nuts on her job done she's like
what the [ __ ]
you're supposed to let me know stupid
supposed to tell me it's coming check
mark
job done
the balls don't miss the bows
your lick beneath my sack that's all
right with me as well
ah [ __ ] yeah so what do you think that
dude sounds like topped off man
that's the new question yeah
anytime there's a new
guy on the show yeah new season what do
you think he sounds like getting head
what kind of sounds would that would
that dude make what about brett what
kind of sounds would brett make
oh
oh
that that sound oh
oh yeah
oh you're so smart
are you so smart with it you give the
smartest head
it's because of that big brain
i just make sure priya giving a [ __ ]
but then stopping halfway through and
like talking about your penis like a
medical thing yeah it's like bending it
pointing at it this is the main vein
yeah this is actually where all the
blood if i bit here you would die yeah
right yeah right no yeah yeah totally
and if i
snip this you'll never have children
okay
she puts a finger in your ears yeah
and this is the prostate yeah this right
here quite thick you might have cancer
[Laughter]
what
yeah you might have cancer
i could feel you got a quite large
prostate
anyways what do you think that dude
sounds like getting topped off
[Laughter]